listening to
courage with
and Terry morning
originally started the book just that it
was going to be about vomit my
experience and vomit but then I realized
that that wouldn't service the community
enough that I needed to really go
outside my experience with vomit and
that bomb it was one way of doing things
and there were many other ways of doing
things and one of the approaches are the
philosophies of the book and I'll just
repeat again is that every film is
different and so it's not just one path
for every film and I try to present it I
try to present the different options are
you can do this or you can do this you
can do this it's like I'm not didactic
about anyone approach and especially I
don't i'm not a firm believer that
everything has to be DIY i think it's
very difficult to do everything viy I
almost would say that pure DIY is a last
resort because it's so much work if you
can partner with companies who have done
this stuff before that are reliable and
pay people and you feel like you're
going to get paid go with them they i
reinvent the wheel you know it's a
matter of but what a lot of filmmakers
will find is that either they don't have
those companies for any rights or they
have maybe they have a DVD company maybe
they have an aggregator but then there's
still plenty of other rights that are
left that they need to do on their own
or let fall by the wayside then i do
recommend the blog i think be blocks are
good because people respond to visual
information as much or more as text
information but i also think you need to
Twitter and i think you need to facebook
any i think you need to do all of it you
know and you know and figure out a way
and use some of the technology out there
like TweetDeck and bit ly and ping that
will service that will send your
information out to multiple sites so
that you're not having to eat there's a
way to automate some of this and some of
us get an intern on some of this you
don't necessarily need for all of this a
producer to be doing it although there
should be a producer coordinating it but
a lot of this stuff can be done by
interns so I would say it's mostly the
web work that you do is very important
during during production and also
creating assets you have to cheat it I
you know this is nothing new to this
world that were the new indie world you
have to shoot good stills you have to be
shooting behind-the-scenes footage and
you have to be creating you know extra
content to help promote your film